امام مستشفى الاتحاد في نابلس وهو مستشفى
محاصر في ظل ايضا اقتحامات واعتقالات
شهدتها نابلس ضعنا في اخر
التطورات نعم طبعا الاليات الاسرائيليه
انسحبت من مدينه نابلس لم تعد هنا رغم
الحديث من قبل بعض الاهالي ان هناك
محاولات لاقتحام بعض الاحياء جنوبي
المدينه في هذه الاثناء وهذه الليله
اقتحمت القوات الاسرائيليه وركزت عمليات
الدهم والاعتقال وال اقتحام في الاحياء
وسط مدينه نابلس في حي الفاطميه وحي
رفيديه وحي المخفيه وحي الاتحاد حيث نقف
في هذه الاثناء من هذا الحي اعتقلت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيليه هذه الليله شابا
فلسطينيا بعد ان دهمت منزله وكذلك دهمت
القوات الاسرائيليه منزل مواطن فلسطيني
على مفرق زواتا وكذلك مواطن اخر في منطقه
الجبل الشمالي من مدينه نابلس نفذت قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي سلسله اعتقالات في
هذه المدينه وكذلك في بلده كراوت جنوبي
مدينه نابلس كانت هناك عمليه اقتحام
اسرائيليه نفذها اكثر من 20 جنديا نزلوا
الى هذه القريه من مستوطنه عليلي المقامه
على اراضي المواطنين الفلسطينيين هذه
القوات انتشرت في احياء وشوارع القريه
ودهمت عددا من منازل المواطنين
الفلسطينيين دفعت بعائلات الى العراء خارج
المنزل رغم البرد القارس الذي كان خيم على
المنطقه في الليله الماضيه وعائلات اخرى
احتجزتها هذه القوات داخل غرف المنزل
واطلقت الغاز المسيل للدموع في ال احياء
وصوب منازل المواطنين الفلسطينيين وفي
الحقيقه قوات الاحتلال التي دخلت الى
قريوت اثارت حاله من الرعب في صفوف
الفلسطينيين خاصه انها دهمت منازل فيها
اطفال ونساء خربت وكسرت بشكل متعمد كما
يقول الاهالي ممتلكات الفلسطينيين في هذه
المنازل على الرغم انها لم تدخل منازل
مواطنين كانت تريد اعتقالهم هذا ما يعني
يفسره اهالي الا ان ما جرى كان عباره عن
حمله ترويع للمواطنين الفلسطينيين وكذلك
كانت هناك اقتحامات ليليه لمنطقه لقرى في
منطقه بيت لحم جنوبي الضفه الغربيه حيث
نفذت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي ايضا
عمليات اعتقال هناك وصادرت مركبات وفي
مدينه الخليل ايضا اقتحمت قوات من جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي مخيم العروب شمالي ال
مدينه واعتقلت ثلاثه شبان هم اسرى محررين
وكذلك مدينه يطا جنوبي مدينه الخليل التي
صادرت منها ثلاثه مركبات تابعه لمواطنين
فلسطينيين بذلك و يعني قبل الاحصائيه
الرسميه التي لم تصدر بعد حول عدد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين لهذه الليله وصل عدد الاسرى
الفلسطينيين في الضفه الغربيه ومدينه
القدس منذ السابعه من اكتوبر وحتى هذا
اليوم الى
4520 اسيرا
فلسطينيا من كافه ارجاء الضفه الغربيه من
مدنها وقراها ومخيماتها وكذلك استشهد خلال
ال 24 ساعه دعيني اشير في الضفه الغربيه
سته شهداء فلسطينيين في طول كرم في رام
الله وفي جنين و على امتداد الضفه الغربيه
ايضا واخرهم كان في بلده دير لغصون اثناء
محاولته اجتياز جدار الفصم العنصري شكرا
لك محمد خيري مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من
نابلس